MALE SPEAKER: Hey, developers.
You know what really
grinds my gears?
When I'm at a
store and I realize
I forgot that 15% off coupon
I got in the mail or the gift
card I got for my birthday.
Or I'm at the
register, and I can't
remember which phone number
to use with my loyalty card.
It's 2016, folks.
There's got to be a better way.
Well, that's where you come in.
With Save to Android
Pay Deep Links,
it's now easier
than ever for you
to digitize your loyalty
program, gift cards,
and offers.
Once you do that, I can start
storing them on my phone
so they're always with
me and ready to use.
The easier it is for me to save,
the more likely I am to shop.
So we both win.
To get you started,
I'll show you
how to digitize a loyalty
card and add it to an e-mail
so that it's super easy
for a customer to save it.
First, you'll need to create a
Save to Android Pay Deep Link.
Step 1, create a class.
Step 2, define the
object in JSON.
Step 3, create
the JSON web token
or JOT by signing
with your private key.
Step 4, place the
JOT and class ID
in the Deep Link URL seen here.
And now that you've
created the Deep Link,
put it behind a
button in an email.
When a customer
gets your e-mail,
they can simply tap on the
Save to Android Pay button,
confirm, and boom-- their
loyalty card will be
instantly added to Android Pay.
What's that?
No more entering phone
numbers at checkout?
So I've just shown you how to
embed the Save to Android Pay
Deep Link in an email.
But did you know you can
use it anywhere a link
works, including SMS, your
website, or your Android app?
And once a customer saves your
digital cards to Android Pay,
you can use our REST
API to provide them
with really cool real-time
info, including how many loyalty
points they've earned,
their gift card
balance, or their offer
redemption status.
I'd like to see you do
that with a physical card.
So what are you're waiting for?
Check out our tutorial
on how to get started.
In a few short
hours, your customers
can start saving your loyalty
program, gift cards, and offers
to Android Pay so they'll
never lose track of them again.
Plus, it'll be easier
than ever for them to use
these items at your store.
They can have the
cashier scan the barcode.
Or if you've
implemented Smart Tap,
they can simply tap their
phone to the terminal.
[MUSIC PLAYING]